when was the last time
you walk down a street
in a city with new buildings
i want to talk to you about the problem
that we all know exists
in our towns and cities
we're increasingly surrounded
by characterless buildings
i believe we're living through an
epidemic of boringness
with a few exceptions we all know
that new buildings will be dead and
monotonous
everywhere is the same dull flat
straight shiny
inhuman
they're what my daughter calls
mech buildings
these buildings justify themselves
as being functional
i'm a designer of buildings and i've
been told so many times that forms
should follow function
meaning if i work out mechanically how a
building goes together well the outcome
will somehow inevitably look good
this mantra form follows function is a
century old
and it sounds good doesn't it
who can argue with that
surely any extra detail is just
silly unnecessary decoration
i want to talk
about the function
that's crucial
that i believe is missing
the function
of emotion
and when i say emotion i mean the
ability of buildings
to mean something to us
to lift our spirits to connect us
buildings affect us
we walk around them we look up at them
and for most of us for the vast majority
of the time they just leave us feeling
indifferent
so if i took all of us to a city
and said
which bit would you like to go to
would you like to go to
the old bit
or the new bit
you've given me my answer already
we all know
instinctively the majority of you going
to are going to pick the old bit
why because we all know the new bit will
be characterless and boring
so
where did all the lumps and bumps on
buildings go
the shadows the textures the
three-dimensionality the high points of
light
how did it all become so two-dimensional
so
simplistic and devoid of character
well it turns out
i'm not the only one who's alarmed by
what's happening in our towns and cities
there's research showing that these
buildings
aren't just
simplistic and monotonous
they're harming us
they're bad for our mental health
causing stress in our brains as we walk
around them
they're bad for our physical health
making us take longer to recover from
illness inside them
and they're also bad for societal health
increasing the likelihood of crime and
anti-social behavior
but this gets most sinister
when we step back
and think about the climate crisis
unfolding around us
immense emphasis has been placed
on the impact
of cars
and aviation
and in this 2019 study
aviation was responsible for 2.1 percent
of greenhouse gas emissions but the
crazy elephant in the room
is that the construction industry as a
whole
is responsible for a whopping 38 per
and in america every year a billion
square foot of buildings
are destroyed
and rebuilt
that's the equivalent of half of
washington dc
being deconstructed just to be
reconstructed
and this isn't just in the us this is
global
in the uk
we demolish 50 000 buildings a year
the average age of a commercial building
in the uk
is 40 years
so that means if i had been born as a
commercial building i would have been
killed 12 years ago
it's quite straightforward
when people
don't
love and i'm using the word love love
buildings
they're more likely to demolish them
i feel those two dots haven't been
connected together
but when you make a building
one of the most expensive things you can
possibly do
there are understandably huge pressures
of cost
of time
of politics and egos and regulations and
the status quo
these forces of soullessness
are immense
and
change is scary for everybody myself
included
but i'm convinced that emotion
is the crucial function
that's been forgotten
there are however a tiny handful
of people who do understand and are
trying to address this here's a few of
them
in france sue fujimoto
has designed this amazingly textured
apartment building
in burkina faso
france's cara has made this soulful
health center
in lebanon
lena gottman architecture
has been using
splendidly thick walls to make character
full housing
and in the uk acme studio
have been bringing personality and
detail to city center buildings
i thought i'd now show you a few
examples of ways my own studio has been
trying to address this too
in cape town
there was a huge century-old disused
grain silo that was once used for
storing maize from throughout south
africa that was at significant risk of
being demolished
we proposed to not knock it down
but instead turned it into africa's
first major institution for contemporary
african artists
we
you haven't seen it yet
um
um
we
we took one of the original grain you
might get disappointed now
we too
we took one of the original grains of
corn that had been stored in the
original building
and we cut it out of the heart of that
building
and around that put 80 galleries
and most of our work was about restoring
and reinvigorating a historical
structure
but
central part of our vision
was using our limited budget
to create the most compelling hearts
possible
with those gigantic tubes
and
the key thing was how we could make
people not just stand at the outside and
admire a structure but how we could pull
them into the inside
where curiosity would then do the rest
of the work
and
you enter under the grain hoppers where
the grain used to drop onto the conveyor
belts
and we loved that by cutting through the
original historic extraordinary
structure
we could expose and share the building's
idiosyncrasies
and like these nooks and crannies that
are they help to give the the project
it's soulfulness
and
on the top is a sculpture garden with a
glass floor and if you see those babies
on the glass just there
this is their view
the finished museum
is raw
it's rough
but it's true
and it was an honor to bring this
historic structure back into life
in singapore
we searched for solutions
for why would people be excited
to learn in universities anymore
in this new digital era where you can
do virtually everything online
and you can even get a phd lying in bed
i've heard
why do we need university buildings
anymore well
we believe they're where you come
together to have ideas
to meet your future business partner or
the person you're going to set up a
not-for-profit with
yet this has been the typical experience
polystyrenes ruling piles
no natural daylight
the least inspiring place to meet people
so to counter that
we made a corridor loose university
building where the students can all see
each other
a building which
has no front and has no back
and it's not one building it's actually
12 buildings
our goal was to invent a new kind of
tropical architecture
that used the minimum possible energy
where you learn
in cornerless classrooms
where those professors and teachers work
with you
rather than dictating to you
where people can be inspired by learning
but encouraged to linger and it's open
24 hours
and when i was last in singapore
i had jet lag and it was two o'clock in
the morning
and so i went along and there were
students there just quietly working and
connecting
in yorkshire in the uk
we had the chance to humanize a
treatment building at one of the uk's
largest cancer hospitals so when you
think of the worst building environments
you've ever been to
surely hospitals are at the top of that
list
there's some of the most stress and fear
inducing places
you can possibly be in
so
we set ourselves the mission
to make a non-clinical building
where
you could feel vulnerable
and cry
and feel protected
and come together as a community
but
our sight was on the last bit of
greenery at the hospital
and we didn't want to be the ones who
dropped a big box and wiped out all that
greenery
so we wondered instead could we amplify
the greenery that we knew could help
with healing
so just like those dinosaur models made
from plywood that slot together
we slotted together giant plywood
to make three structures
to hold up three major gardens and make
a garden building
this building has 17 000 plants
23 000 bulbs and actually a 436
biodiversity increase on that site
oh thank you
now our goal was to really make
somewhere where people could come
together
and where by focusing on the emotion of
the users
to really try to make an architecture of
hope
finally in shanghai
we had the chance that's typical of our
time
the challenge of bigness
to make a three and a half million
square foot site
a building project
on a site that's 480 meters long
where typically this is what would be
built
the site was so big that the empire
state building could fit on it lying
sideways
so
to make this
cost efficient
structurally effective we needed a
thousand columns on a grid
so we decided to not just decorate boxes
but to let the columns be our heroes
and to connect with the park to one side
and the art district on the other side
and try to bring them together into one
the finished project is called a
thousand trees
every one of those columns has a chinese
mountain tree semi-mature mountain tree
on top and nourishment and drainage and
lighting
and
moisture and because every column is the
best place to put a heavy load
and it has
hundreds of outdoor terraces
and it has
shading
and it has we hope the necessary
complexity to create the human
engagement in a project at such a scale
we also worked
with local artists to embed their work
into our vision
to really make a collaborative project
together
and that carries through
all the way to the inside
and this project
opened at the end of last year the first
half of it
and we have a hundred thousand people
going to every day
and it wasn't just about
trees and plants but even structural
columns were our friends to humanize the
project at such a scale
so
i'm not saying that there's any one
language or approach
to deal with this epidemic
of boring
just like in nature we've learned the
vast importance of biodiversity
we now desperately need architectural
diversity
my goal
is to try to help trigger
a global humanizing movement
that no longer tolerates soulless
inhuman places
what if our buildings inspired us to
want to adapt and adjust and repair them
we can't keep knocking down the
buildings around us all the time
let's stop building
40-year buildings
and let's build a thousand year
buildings please join me
thank you